[Musique]
après une amputation de la jambe une
prothèse peut permettre aux patient de
recouvrer sa mobilité c'est une approche
efficace mais qui comporte son lot de
défi une opération étonnante offre
maintenant de nouvelles possibilités
[Musique]
annoncée à la plus belle journée
d'automne qu'on n'avait pas vu à date un
couple s'offre une dernière balade à
moto avant la fin des beaux jours on va
descendre
et à 11h30 du matin moi je l'avais toute
collée en arrière et à maintenir comme
ça avec ses bras je me sentais tellement
bien c'était vraiment un bon bon bon
sentiment
mais cette sortie en amoureux va tourner
au drame
face à moi puis je trouvais qu'en
prenait large un peu donc moi j'ai fait
ok je vois je vais me tasser puis pour
une raison pour une autre je sais pas
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé mais j'ai senti
un impact sur moi
percuté par le véhicule pierre Marignier
va reprendre conscience dans le fossé
que j'avais plus de bandes manquer un
bout sur mon je voyais mon genou joyeux
mon pantalon ça l'arrêter au genou
transporter d'urgence à l'hôpital du
sacré-cœur à Montréal il va devoir être
amputé de la jambe gauche sa conjointe
blessée encore plus gravement subira
aussi une amputation
bonjour moi c'est Marignier les mois
suivants monsieur Marignier a dû
apprendre à vivre avec une prothèse
dans les circonstances sa réadaptation a
été remarquable mais il voudrait en
faire encore plus c'est drôle l'alarme
même matinée
pour rester actif il donne un coup de
main au garage d'un ami
le problème c'est qu'il ne peut pas
s'activer très longtemps ça commence à
être très humide dans ma prothèse sa
jambe artificielle devient vite
inconfortable
mais quand je fais beaucoup d'exercices
que je suis beaucoup mais le moniant
aussi il vient tout en soi et puis
toutes les silicon avait tout trempe
puis là je peux pas je peux plus rien
faire avec nous avec l'effort
l'emboiture qui fixe la prothèse sur sa
cuisse devient instable ça provoque des
plaies et ça peut lui faire perdre
l'équilibre je retire la prothèse pour
enlever la sueur c'est accumulé dans mon
emboiture pour être capable de la
remettre la la sécher comme il faut que
de la remettre pour que une bonne
adhérence avec la peau pour empêcher la
prothèse de bouger des gestes fastidieux
que Monsieur Marignier espère bientôt ne
plus avoir à répéter
et voilà bonjour bonjour vous allez bien
et merci il rencontrait l'orthopédiste
Robert Turcotte qui lui a proposé une
chirurgie novatrice une
ostéo intégration
[Musique]
un implant une tige de métal sera fixée
dans l'os de sa cuisse il pourra ensuite
facilement y accrocher une prothèse
amovible
c'est un peu comme un implant dentaire
on fait ces dérivés des implants
dentaires donc on met un bout de métal à
travers un os qui va sortir au travers
de la peau et qui va permettre
d'accrocher une prothèse
[Musique]
en 2019 la Régie de l'assurance maladie
du Québec a annoncé qu'elle financerait
une cinquantaine de ses opérations par
an pendant trois ans
pandémie oblige les chirurgies ont été
ralenties mais ceux qui ont pu en
bénéficier ne regrette pas selon le
docteur Turcotte
[Musique]
c'est le jour et la nuit en termes de
confort les gens portent leurs prothèse
toute la journée les gens n'ont pas mal
la peau on peut même de peau de sudation
la prothèse tourne pas durant la journée
et ils ont aussi une sensation
à travers la prothèse qui va dans l'os
par la tige de ressentir le sol sur
lequel il marche
encouragé par ces informations pierre
Marignier atteint son opération avec
impatience avec un objectif être sur sa
nouvelle jambe atteint pour assister au
grand prix de Formule 1 du Canada en
juin
la semaine suivante c'est le jour J le
même enthousiasme l'anime le matin de
l'opération
c'est comme un cadeau
l'intervention va durer deux heures
d'abord le chirurgien doit raccourcir le
fémur pour qu'il ait la bonne longueur
puis il creuse l'intérieur de l'os qui
va recevoir l'implant
en cours d'opération il choisit un
implant plus étroite prévu pour éviter
de fracturer l'os au moment d'insérer la
tige de titane
l'implant doit être inséré profondément
sur une quinzaine de centimètres à
l'intérieur du fémur pour être bien
stable ensuite la peau est percée pour
créer une ouverture qui laissera sortir
la tige à l'extérieur de la jambe
[Musique]
au travers de la pompe c'est le plus
controversé de cette technique là
l'ostéo intégration offre des avantages
en termes de confort mais elle comporte
aussi des risques en premier lieu les
infections
[Musique]
que des germes rentrent par l'intérieur
et infecte soit la peau soit la plupart
des infections observées sont mineurs et
traitées avec des antibiotiques plus
rarement des abcès peuvent se former
de l'os qui nécessiterait de retirer
l'implant et ça ça arrive très rarement
avez-vous vu ça donc nous sommes pas
arrivés disons dans les gens qui ont au
moins 10 ans de suivi
90% des gens retiennent leur implant
donc à 10 ans on peut considérer 90% de
l'amputé va avoir son implant ça fait
bien passé
[Musique]
nous retrouvons pierre marinier quelques
semaines plus tard à l'Institut de
réadaptation gingera l'Inde à Montréal
bonjour monsieur marinier comment ça va
bien toute une équipe encore sa
récupération qui doit se faire
progressivement sur une période de 4
mois
en fait
qu'on va utiliser la petite prothèse
petit à petit les patients recommencent
à mettre du poids sur leurs jambes
on va commencer aujourd'hui seulement
avec 5 kg puis on va augmenter comme ça
graduellement jusqu'à 50 kg complet
le fait attention là que tu es un choix
bien droit qu'en fait l'implant est fait
avec des petits trous à l'intérieur et
gratuitement ce qui va se former c'est
que là tu vas rentrer dans ces petits
trous et ça va devenir ostéo intégré et
ce processus là se fait graduellement
sur plusieurs semaines alors qu'on
permet aux patients d'augmenter la
charge puisque quand on met de la charge
ça augmente ça stimule la formation des
eaux et donc ça va vraiment permettre
cette
ostéo intégration c'est le grand jour
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour
ok
après quelques semaines sans mettre le
pied par terre c'est le moment pour
Monsieur Marignier d'installer sa
prothèse en un seul clic
le temps d'apprivoiser sa nouvelle
mobilité c'est bon ça et même peut-être
retrouver de vieilles sensations quelque
chose qui est vraiment très intéressant
c'est qu'il développe quelque chose qui
s'appelle de l'ostéoperception donc ils
vont commencer à sentir une partie de
l'argent à travers l'implant à travers
l'os et pour des gens qui sentaient plus
leurs pieds depuis des années ça va leur
permettre de savoir où leurs pieds dans
l'espace mieux qu'avant ça va leur
permettre de marcher à l'extérieur plus
longtemps porter leur prothèses
longtemps puis de fonctionner vraiment
plus normalement d'avoir une meilleure
qualité de vie de ce côté-là
sous la plante du pied là on va c'est
fou là
le fait de pas avoir l'emboiture c'est
comme la continuité de ma jambe c'est
vraiment la conçu comme si ma jambe elle
avait repris sa forme presque originale
malheureusement l'ostéo intégration ne
convient pas à tous les amputés non
seulement elle vise ceux qui ont des
difficultés à supporter une prothèse
avec une emboiture mais la liste des
contre-indications est assez longue
par exemple les fumeurs ça c'est ils
sont pas éligibles pour le soin
intégration parce que ça altère la
circulation puis ça augmente le risque
d'infection les patients qui sont
amputés à cause de diabète ou de
troubles de circulation de la même façon
ça diminue l'immunité il y a certains
médicaments aux problèmes de santé qui
peuvent aussi diminuer l'immunité et
puisqu'une des problématiques en lien
avec le son intégration c'est d'un
risque accru d'infection mais c'est pas
cela sont pas éligibles malheureusement
pour l'instant pour le soin intégration
à cela il faut ajouter l'état d'esprit
des patients un psychologue fait
d'ailleurs font partie de l'équipe de la
clinique on a eu des patients dont on a
raccordé la chirurgie à façon à ce
qu'ils aillent travailler sur la douleur
chronique sur leur abus de substance sur
leurs éléments de dépression alors
certainement que il y a un côté motif
qui doit être adressé parce que les
amputés ont souvent un bagage là suite à
la chirurgie qu'ils ont subi qui est
lourent alors donc on les aide aussi la
scalifier pour l'opération c'est comme
la continuité de ma jambe c'est vraiment
pierre Marignier la perspective de
retrouver une meilleure mobilité a suffi
son enthousiasme est tel qu'après une
séance trop intense l'équipe de
réadaptation doit le rappeler à l'ordre
puis je me suis dit debout sur une jambe
peut-être que je serai capable de aller
trop vite
quelques jours plus tard c'est donc avec
une certaine prudence et beaucoup
d'émotions qu'il se rend debout au Grand
Prix de Formule 1
tu le mérites depuis ce matin j'ai des
textos des enfants qui me disent bon
weekend papa bonne course tu le mérites
puis je ferai juste répondre des like et
des like et des gros cœur
sur la piste les performances des
pilotes le ramènent à sa propre histoire
j'ai regardé
de course mais j'ai jamais fait de
vitesse en moto j'ai jamais été
l'accident qui est arrivé c'est un
accident anodin j'aime les courbes
j'aime le circuit mais je suis pas un
lion le petit point lion le travail
n'est pas terminé pierre doit encore se
déplacer en béquille pendant quelques
mois le dernier droit d'un parcours
parsemé d'obstacles pour moi c'est comme
si j'étais un nouveau pierre
comment tu vois celui-ci par rapport au
précédent
de la victoire
pas plus que ça quoi
c'est vraiment ça
[Musique]